[Music]
ibaka welcome to our new year's special
what a wild 12 months it's been from
kovid to the crime crisis to major biden
missteps high profile tries celebrity
news and everything else in between
we've covered a lot and now we're ready
to have some fun
we have a great show ahead including our
resolutions and predictions for 2022 but
we're also going to see who's paying
attention this year not me
with a very special trivia battle and
don't miss our top videos from 2021
and plus we're answering some of your
fan mail questions but first let's do
this
it's our big five stories of 2021. so
we're just taking a look at the top
headlines from this past year
my biggest story and i know what yours
might be what yours might how would you
know that because i have someone in my
ear but mine is the kyle rittenhouse
trial and i'll explain why
we had cameras in the courtroom for this
trial if there had not been cameras in
the courtroom this country would have
perceived what happened that
scary day very very differently so it
was almost like a formal education in
prosecutorial misconduct in
constitutional law
and
everything that the media tried to spin
one way ended up being a complete
disaster so we saw the trial in real
time we saw a jury deliberate
methodically and
i people at this table believe that was
pretty cut and dry self-defense
and it opened people's eyes i think
dagon you would agree that it opened the
country's eyes to a lot of factors that
have played pretty heavily in this year
liberal friends of mine uh following
people on in on instagram and twitter
they were shocked at what they saw
because it was completely the opposite
story of this of what the lies that were
peddled by everybody and from joe biden
on down as soon as it happened
and and i mean as soon as it happened
like in the new york times right after
the shooting they were talking about uh
kyle rittenhouse's race but not the race
of the two two people he killed and it's
still reverberating you could have
lawsuits
slapped against some of these big media
corporations for defamation slander
libel what have you i don't think jesse
that that's really going to be the
aftermath i think that what will be the
takeaway is how the country was divided
and people were rooting for a a
a
finale rooting for
you know
how it was going to turn out they wanted
some people wanted them to be
acquitted other wanted them to be
convicted and people chose upsides based
on ideology not on the evidence it was
very distressing to me to see how
politics infected even something as
basic as this
and i hated that they were cheerleaders
and and jeering depending on your point
well i was rooting for self-defense and
i think that should be noted dana what
was your biggest story of the year
besides how i saved the world going to
number one i mean that was pretty
amazing i got to number three congrats
my first one got to number one oh wow
we're in good company you get your
second one we'll see you're all you're
always going to be number one thank you
oh so nice yes it's new year's eve i
have to be nice um so i could have
chosen a whole bunch of different
stories but i i chose one that i think
will have
impact for many decades to come and that
was that this was the year that new uh
space travel took place
when you had virgin galactic and blue
origin
basically get up there and take
civilians
into space and it might have only been
an 11-minute ride but you think about
what could happen there's so many
ambitious goals that are coming out of
these programs and time magazine named
elon musk the man of the year and it's
not just because of electric vehicles i
don't think i think that it's much more
about the vision and the pioneer spirit
and the next frontier which is space my
runner-up for man of the year was bill
hemmer
robbed almost made the cover almost oh
no 2022 you got this there's still a
chance by the way happy new year you too
happy new year
here we go and
anybody like myself we like your choice
by the way dana and i talked about this
the other day i love the choice uh that
was a good one for far-reaching um
effects down the road
i've been in fox news for 16 years eight
of those 16 years i've been in times
square for new year's eve freezing my
butt off and here you really and this
year no dana they send the crew down to
nashville tennessee what's up with that
someone doesn't like me do you want my
story of the year why don't you go ahead
i think we're all done with space dana
wow but i i don't want to belittle it at
all i think that you're absolutely right
it is the vision of the future we all
want to be those astronauts uh my only
downside is so few people can reasonably
participate for now for now and musk
told uh bezos to spend less time in the
hot tub i don't know what that means but
i think it was a dig i think it was you
want it go ahead bill um i think without
a doubt this is the image
with all due respect to my partner her
colleague and co-anchor
of what happened on that monday morning
august 16th in kabul you cannot erase
this memory it's an international
embarrassment
the u.s military deserved better than
this after 20 years serving in that war
and this was a c-17 u.s air force
rolling down the tarmac in kabul with 20
year old men bouncing off the side the
scene was bad i don't know where it
leads i don't know what happens as a
consequence dan hoffman was with us on
america's newsroom earlier in the month
and he talked about dictatorships being
on the march and 2021 into 2022 and what
he talked about was perhaps at a rate
that we have not seen since world war ii
i don't know if he's right about that
between putin and xi and iran
it's been since the 1980s since we had a
president with a bully pulpit who was
talking the way that ronald reagan did i
think we're a long way from that right
now in this current white house we had a
democracy summit earlier in the month of
december there are fledgling democracies
right now in places like ukraine
and taiwan
that we hope will hold on into the new
year and beyond and we'll see what comes
as a result of this because as i said
the scene was bad i don't know where it
leads i just hope it leads to a good
place interesting thing about it was
that that was the mark for when
president biden's poll numbers really
started to go down and then everything
else sort of piled on on top yeah that
was my pick for uh the year but a little
birdie told me that it was yours so i
went with rittenhouse
but i think you're right i think and no
disrespect to space in terms of law
like an optimistic story i was like
trying to find the good news but we were
all here
in the news room and aft during the
afghanistan situation in august and i
think everybody understood how serious
of an event that was
story of the year dagen mcdowell the
floor is yours inflation inflation a
huge hardship for so many americans
consumer prices are surging at the at
the fastest space in almost 40 years
wages are falling
for many americans when adjusting for
the that inflation those price increases
so the federal reserve and the democrats
screwed up in unison
in both uh monetary and fiscal policy
respectively fed chief jay powell and
his cronies at the fed they were way too
cavalier starting in 2020 letting prices
get hot hot hot deciding to kind of let
it run ignoring the signs even in the
spring that prices were getting out of
hand they kept buying 120 billion
dollars worth of securities every month
of government securities and have kept
interest rates at zero all year and then
the liberal spin thrifts and washington
were loving it because the fed was
sopping up more than half of their
spending so the the central bank bought
more than half of the treasury debt
issued this year and now the white house
is trying to push this giant new welfare
monstrosity making matters worse and
they don't even know what to say about
it when jenn saigon was asked about it
recently she'd blame the gree greedy big
meat greedy big
so the federal reserve has no good
options left whatever they do is going
to be a huge policy mistake
look out below that's my i think all
excellent stories and excellent choices
i think this point about inflation is
that we don't know where it's going to
go next and i would be a fan of the fed
being more hawkish than dovish and i
don't know what that does to the market
in the meantime but we've taken all our
economic weapons out of our own hands
it's like what japan did in the 1990s
taking interest rates down to zero you
can't when you're at zero you have very
few places to go and unfortunately
that's where we are harolda rivera your
turn the biggest story of the year i
think
maybe the biggest story of our lifetimes
is covet
as much as we want to ignore it as much
as it wants as we want to
you know make it
go away it's here we're on the verge of
another surge from this omicron it's
just now spreading like wildfire through
our country we have
50 million americans infected
799 000 dead americans
you know it is
california the most dead seventy five
thousand six hundred texas seventy five
thousand florida sixty two thousand uh
tom hanks rita wilson chris rock tom
brady luke bryant sarah palin lib taylor
uh michael strahan larry king who passed
away ashante nancy gracie i mean the
list goes to the celebrities
almost everybody is important almost
everybody is going to get this
it is so very serious i think that the
municipalities and the mask mandates and
the travel mandates and the vaccine
mandates all the rest of it i think that
they're going to be part of our life for
another year you used the word ignored i
don't think we ignored it i think we've
been living with it every day we try our
best to a quick
i just want to say about the trial with
written house yes you're right about the
cameras in the courtroom but that that
trial would not have turned out the way
it did without the also the visual
medium of the videotapes that were
present in the streets of countries
together it made for a very potent
argument it did and now i feel like i
should change mine to inflation because
if that sticks around that's going to be
very very powerful politically the new
york fed did a public survey about
inflation expectations for the next year
among individuals record high
oh i feel great
thank you hammer could afford it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else